I'm live a lot to talk about today I'm
going to talk about we had a tech
disaster at the studio today I'll deal
with that in a second I want to talk
about Steve Bannon and CPAC I want to
talk about New Trump related polls next
week on the show there's a hilarious
coffee coffee controversy and a lot of
other stuff going on so I'll give people
a second to connect make sure to say
hello in the chat also make sure that
you are getting notifications for when I
go live in order to do this there's sort
of like a a bell icon you can press and
say notify me when this channel puts out
your videos is live etc etc okay so as
people trickle and I'll tell you about
the tech disaster that we had today
total utter disaster of the studio
basically every i'd say like every three
months there's some kind of a tech
disaster and you know the daily
production of the show in order for it
to happen correctly things need to go
off without a hitch because we've got a
schedule every day and we've got you
know pre-production and then the
interview and production and exporting
and videos uploading all this different
stuff so in order to to do something it
doesn't even matter it's too complicated
to explain long story short we use Adobe
Premiere for editing the show and
yesterday after the day's production was
over we upgraded to the latest version
of adobe premiere okay and we needed to
make that upgrade in order to do a
couple of new things so the upgrade went
fine we get into the studio today it all
seems to be working fine but we realize
that what's called Adobe Media encoder
which is it's it's not really part of
Adobe Premiere but it's used in concert
with Adobe Premiere is not the up the
the exporter piece of the software was
not updated correctly a feature was
working incorrectly ok so long story
short we taped the show because we had
to we had to move on with the day we had
we had a show
tape and then we had to get adobe
support to remote into our computer it
took about an hour to get problem one
resolved and we thought okay we're
beyond it let's were delayed an hour
today but that's still okay we build in
more than an hour of sort of leeway into
the day's schedule and then there was
like a second issue where we were we
thought everything was working fine we
exported our video files open them up
and they were black it looked like
everything was working fine but there
was no video so back to remote Adobe
support which to their credit is very
good they take they take control of your
computer and fix the issue well and then
then you move on so we're still now like
the the YouTube clips were a little bit
late getting up today and our affiliates
are getting the show a little bit later
than normal although I think it should
should still be okay and this happens
like every three months and you deal
with it you know I mean it's we have
tremendous people working for us we've
got the best people around us and we're
working it out okay so that went on hi
to everybody who's strolling into the
live stream remember if you're not
subscribed to the channel please
subscribe I assume most people are here
because they're subscribed and they were
notified that we're live but if you're
not subscribed please do and please
select to be notified when we go live
that's also another thing I will be
doing live shoutouts and thank yous to
people who sign up for membership at
david pakman.com during the stream one
such person has already signed up that's
Robert night Robert thank you so much
for signing up signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership we also have
super chat turned on if you want to use
the super chat feature do it and I hope
we'll get some super chat questions
comments etc okay there's this whole a I
don't know why I find this so funny but
there's this hilarious pseudo scandal
that's happening on the david pakman
show subreddit at david pakman.com slash
reddit yesterday I was talking about
David Pakman coffee which is available
on our website
and Pat producer Pat sort of casually
mentioned his Keurig machine that he
uses I am I am Bigley anti Keurig and so
uh Pat did mention or try to mention
that he uses like the refill pod rather
than regularly using new pods which is a
big issue in terms of wasting plastic
and blah blah blah and a thread showed
up on our reddit discussion forum at
david pakman.com slash reddit saying
that i was visibly shaken by the
revelation that people were just stunned
by pat admitting that he uses a Keurig
and then another user who goes by the
clever name of gigantic meaty balls or
balls if i were to say it the way my New
York friends would say it actually
created a poll which is looking to
assess whether pat deserves to have some
kind of on-air punishment for consuming
Keurig coffee pods and currently the
voting is two to one right so
sixty-seven percent say that yes Pat has
disgraced himself and demand requires or
were deserves some kind of on-air
punishment for using Keurig pods and
then one third thirty-three percent say
no that Pat absolutely has the right to
do that without being punished so anyway
this entire coffee controversy is
hilarious and I had people emailing me I
had a bunch people say hey I'm from
Seattle and here's why Pat's Keurig
admission is deplorable even though he's
talking about the recycled but the
reusable pod blah blah blah blah blah so
anyway check that out on our reddit
discussion forum we've got nearly 3,000
of our uh viewers listeners audience
members etc on the reddit discussion
forum right now and the Pat coffee
controversy is uh absolutely absolutely
hilarious a big thank you to Linda
Chapman who just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership membership
is the number one funding source for the
show we do have a coupon code its i
voted 17 and that gets you a huge or
huge I
should say forty percent discount off of
membership and I say hey if you want the
discount take it we want as many people
buying in to what we're doing at any
level don't pay full price use the
coupon code I voted 17 and i'll be doing
continuing to do live thank yous and
shout outs during the show okay there's
a mother jones article now already when
i say mother jones some people will say
oh mother jones you know the term
they'll use blank news that's the
popular one right now but mother jones
is actually done pretty well with their
revelations investigations into not just
Donald Trump but a number of different
politicians and they have a story out
dated today at 6am by russ choma and
it's called Donald Trump's mystery 50
million or more loan and it's pointing
out to a number of loans that are coming
from an undisclosed a mystery donor it's
unclear who the lender is and Trump owes
Chicago unit acquisition LLC I'm sorry
Trump owns Chicago unit acquisition LLC
the LLC is owed 50 million or more by
Trump so the question here is why is a
trump owned firm that has a 50 million
plus note from Trump not worth anything
because on the disclosures we've seen
from Donald Trump this firm is listed as
not worth anything and the answer to
this could be that that business that
LLC has its own debts which cancel out
its value and then the question is well
who holds that debt who holds that 50
million dollar debt in this LLC that is
negating the assets value such that
Trump is reporting it as not having any
value and this is an investigation
that's going on there's all sorts of on
record
data about interest that is being paid
related to this LLC so it's very very
strange Mother Jones is looking into it
we're going to talk about it on the on
the Monday show and it is yet another
one of those concerns about Donald
Trump's finances we've already got 12
people that I've had to ban one who
called me a [ __ ] jus listen if you want
to troll under the radar either call me
a [ __ ] or call me a jew but when you go
cuck jus it attracts so much attention
that you know you're going to you're
going to end up getting yourself blocked
for our members who are asking about why
the full show the full commercial free
show which is a daily member benefit why
that hasn't been uploaded yet there's a
very specific reason why it hasn't been
uploaded which is that at the beginning
of the show I mentioned we had a big
tech disaster today and this has
basically delayed us about an hour and a
half and so everything is about an hour
and a half behind or a little bit more
we are getting today's show out to our
radio affiliates to our TV affiliates
etc etc and so the members show is a
little bit delayed emails are flooding
in asking about it but it's going to be
it's going to be back on the the will be
caught up hopefully soon within the next
half hour to 45 minutes all right big
thank you to Wesley smoke Wesley smoke
who just signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership using the coupon code i
voted 17 that gets you a forty percent
off members get the daily show as one
long video with no commercials instead
of those three to five minute videos
that we normally upload to youtube you
get one long video normally uploaded by
four or 430 delayed a couple of hours
today because of the tech situation we
also do a daily bonus show I don't know
why I'm doing air quotes it it's called
the bonus show it is a quote bonus show
but it is also called the bonus show
every single day for members and a whole
bunch of other member benefits okay so
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code i voted 17 0
who has a watched so far what has been
going on at CPAC there's been some very
very interesting stuff happening at CPAC
let me pull up my notes here on Steve
benen Steve Bannon uh spoke at CPAC and
he had I can only really describe it as
a sort of deliberately softer image of
sorts his presentation was of the sort
of thoughtful conservative who wants to
be held accountable by whoever it is
whether it's conservatives or or not and
my notes here are starting to play an ad
uh and I i found the entire thing really
pretty interesting because Bannon is
sort of framing himself as the guy who
has come to power at a key moment in
American history which is not wrong but
the reason it's a key moment is because
of the guy Bennett helped get elected in
other words it would not be as key of a
moment we'd be dealing with significant
issues technological automation and
destruction of jobs climate change that
we would be dealing with important stuff
even if Trump weren't the president but
the reason engagement is higher than
ever we just had poll results on today's
show from our website of whether people
are finding themselves more or less
involved with politics since Trump was
elected and eighty-seven percent of our
audience is feeling either somewhat are
significantly more engaged with the
political world since Trump was elected
so the reason that this has become such
a pivotable pivotal and key moment is
because there's a horrifyingly scary guy
running running the White House so it
was interesting to see ban and take this
I don't want to call it a diplomatic
approach but a sort of like a
buttoned-up perspective of we're here to
do really serious work etcetera etcetera
and we're gonna make it happen and we
want to be held accountable and all of
this stuff and he also touted non
accomplishments of Donald Trump I've
talked about about this before Donald
Trump touting
an accomplishment that he got us out of
TPP TPP was dead-on November 15th and it
was dead uh-uh but because House and
Senate Republicans and Democrats were
basically decided that it was dead
before Donald Trump was even elected so
you know taking credit for non
accomplishments using a completely fake
and unbelievable diplomatic tone it was
interesting I only watched a few
highlights of it so far going to watch
more of it a little bit later thank you
to Karen Jones who has sent a to British
Pound super chat you can use the super
chat last live stream we had super chats
ranging from two US dollars all the way
up to 35 US dollars and it's available
it is absolutely available there to you
okay I talked on the show today about
some of the new data regarding Donald
Trump's not only approval but what
percentage of people believe that he's a
strong leader and this is really really
interesting to me because Donald Trump's
big selling point as a candidate I don't
think it was a good selling point was
that he is a good businessperson and a
leader blah blah blah blah blah of
course we have no reason to think that
good business people make good
presidents in fact we don't have any
evidence to suggest that that's the case
but Trump would tout how as a leader
even if you don't agree with him he's
going to be a strong leader and
increasingly Americans don't think he's
a strong leader he's nap down 18 points
in side by side same methodology
Quinnipiac polls from right after the
election to now he has lost 18 points in
terms of the percentage of the
population that thinks he's a strong
leader and he's not a strong leader I
made the case today on the show and we
have a story going up at I'm not sure
I'm kind of look cured exactly what time
it'll be up on YouTube soon Trump is a
weak leader that's what's going on and
if you look at what george w bush it's
amazing how many times i've actually
praised george w bush since the
inauguration of Donald Trump but I've
done it a few times
George W Bush I didn't like what he had
accomplished but he had done a lot more
during his first month as president than
what Donald Trump has done so far uh he
had put out his tax plan and was ready
to actually make it legislation he brock
obama at this point in time had already
done the stimulus package the lilly
Ledbetter Fair Pay Act and the program
that expanded children's health care you
can say you don't like those things you
can say you think that those actions had
negative consequences for the economy or
Society or whatever but it was stuff if
they were things and Donald Trump has
barely done anything it's been mostly
symbolic executive orders and decrees
and the repeal of guidance like the
guidance from the Obama administration
about transgender bathrooms I say sad
low-energy ! trunks just weak if you're
a trump 'used and you think that Donald
Trump has been projecting strength tell
me how he projected strength in terms of
what he actually did not in terms of
what he has said because saying stuff
doesn't actually accomplish things in
almost every case here and if you're
going to say well obstruction come on
he's got the White House he is the White
House he has a Republican House he has a
Republican Senate that was actually an
argument under Barack Obama where Barack
Obama had no choice but to use executive
orders in in some areas because he was
dealing with obstruction that's not
going on right now okay user game fire
74 has sent a ten-dollar and 53 sent
super chat not ten dollars not ten
dollars and fifty cents but ten dollars
and fifty-three sent super chat saying
is the national debt a big deal as
conservatives say it is by the way the
cognitive dissonance from the right
about building an expensive wall and are
liberals hypocrites to complain about
government spending okay when I complain
about government spending under Trump
I'm not complaining about it because I
think there's something wrong with
government spending I'm complaining
because it exposes the hypocrisy of
Trump for example spending as much in
the first month as president
on travel as President Obama spent on
average in an entire year I thought
Trump was the fiscal conservative Trump
also lying saying he would not be taking
vacations he's taken three three
consecutive weekends so far so number
one I don't think liberals liberals
would be hypocritical if they're
complaining generally about government
spending money to stimulate the economy
Trump traveling tomorrow logo and
spending as much in a month as Obama
spent in a year on travel doesn't
doesn't fall under that umbrella the
national debt is not objectively the
problem the problem that many
conservatives want to make it seem we've
talked about this many times and I
encourage you to check out the youtube
videos on it it's sort of more involved
than I can casually go into now you're
not even seeing a strong understanding
from the right as to the difference
between the debt and deficit you will
see people who but you saw people under
Obama and you still see people who say
things like Obama has exploded the
deficit look at our debt clock hold on a
second deficit and debt are two
different things and of course the
deficit is what we're talking about on a
year-to-year basis how much did the
government spend relative to what it
took in in a year and then the total
debt is different you can reduce the
deficit on a year-over-year basis but it
still is more than zero so your total
debt goes up anyway this is probably a
dumb explanation in the sense that you
either already understand this or you're
not going to because I explained it to
you but anyway I have a video explaining
the difference between debt and deficit
so complicated issue in some ways less
complicated issue in other ways but
objectively speaking just complaining
about the debt is not really a good
political critique unless you can
actually connect it to specific ways in
which it's bad for the economy okay Paul
W sending a five dollar super chat
saying please keep the pressure on Trump
it's having an effect believe me we're
going to keep the pressure on and the
more of our stories that go viral the
the better we're able to better better
were able to do that thank you too Gary
Hetzel Gary Hetzel has just signed up
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we're not talking about a lot
of money here if you use my coupon code
i mentioned i voted 17 you're talking
about just pennies a day and it's the
number one funding source for our show
staff salaries are funded by membership
the studio rent is funded by membership
our connectivity and storage space and
ability to provide the show for free to
now 200 non-commercial radio and TV
stations as well as free speech TV on
directv and dish network it's all funded
by membership okay so i really
appreciate everybody who signed up
during the live stream i'll keep doing
thank yous and shout outs david
pakman.com slash membership and there's
a coupon code pay full price if it's
affordable for you if it's not use the
coupon code forty percent off i voted 17
okay next week i want to talk a little
bit about next week on the show we've
still got the friday show tomorrow we've
got phone calls audience questions a
whole bunch of stuff tomorrow but next
week we have some really great things
lined up number one monday we will be
speaking to attorney Mike Papantonio
Mike Papantonio has recently secured a
major settlement in his lawsuit against
DuPont for thousands of plaintiffs over
a leak of the chemical used to make
Teflon which is a carcinogen it's
undeniable causes cancer he's going to
join me on Monday to talk about the
settlement the case the are I'm
fascinated by the logistics and these
big trials of the arguments that
corporate defense counsel try to make to
deflect or distract from what is alleged
liability on their part and then this I
am really looking forward to Stefan DNA
is a doctor who focuses on obesity
weight diet etc we've got a really good
two-part interview coming up with him on
Tuesday and Wednesday okay and we're
going to talk about did obesity exist
when humans were hunter-gatherers
when did obesity first come up a lot of
really really interesting stuff that
will be digging into and then we'll be
doing diet myths uh so-called superfoods
uh is a vegetarian or vegan diet
objectively healthier all of this stuff
we're going to be getting into okay so
Stefan DNA really really good and I
think he's going to be absolutely
tremendous to take a word out of Donald
Trump's vocabulary and then on Thursday
so Monday's Mike Papantonio Tuesday
Wednesday we've got stuff on DNA parts
one and two and then thursday i'm really
looking forward to this Ronald fry is a
military veteran who did a totally
different type of anti-terrorism work he
actually lived in Muslim communities in
the Middle East and fostered
relationships with just average people
who potentially could become radicalized
and and and worked in a different way to
prevent that radicalization from
happening in the first place so we're
going to be talking to him on Thursday
and we're on the number of great
interviews that we have set up right now
I can't even count them i'm not i'm not
going to go beyond next week because
part of it is sometimes interviews get
cancelled or rescheduled but why go
beyond that okay so we've got a really
really good week of shows coming up next
week to everybody who's watching live
right now Thank You number one if you're
not subscribed to our channel please
subscribe to the channel we are now
beyond three hundred and twenty five
thousand subscribers producer Pat ran
some numbers and if we can maintain the
same new subscriber rate during the rest
of this year that we've had so far we
will surpass half a million YouTube
subscribers before the year is out I
think in late november or early december
we could do that so if you're not
subscribed please subscribe if you're
subscribed but you're not notified when
we go live you can also turn that on I
think they're I don't know if it's over
here or over here or down below
somewhere there's like a bell button or
icon and you can
be notified whenever we go live okay we
have a major super chat from michael
smith who said i don't know what's up
today we had a ten-dollar and 53 cents
super chad and now we have a $41 and 72
cents super chat which is the the
biggest super chat we've ever received
so big thank you to Michael do you think
March stuck Trump staff members will be
fired soon if so who else is next up on
the chopping block and why I've been
talking to people who say that uh I like
calling him rinse Priebus but I guess
his actual name is Reince Priebus Reince
Priebus people are saying maybe up on
the chop chopping block and it's not for
any particular reason other than the
Trump White House is chaos and if it's
chaos you look at the chief of staff I
don't know if this has been confirmed I
didn't report on it because it was sort
of an offhanded it was one article I
didn't look for other uh sources on it
but it was that there's a list of
potential replacements for rights
Priebus already being floated and if
you've got a replacement list uh that's
a sign that maybe you're looking to
replace the guy there's another issue
which people in the chat are talking
about which is Kellyanne Conway has
disappeared I mean nobody's heard from
Kellyanne Conway for a while she might
have done one or two interviews but they
did not make headlines and she got
caught making up the Bowling Green
massacre and she was just it was one
boneheaded media appearance after
another she's basically disappeared at
this point so I know that some media
outlets were questioning whether it
makes sense to even interview her
because uh she just lies she just make
stuff up and then she redirects I have
to say she redirects masterfully and she
has this great technique of you ask her
a question about something she doesn't
want to address she'll mention one word
uh in her response but then talk about
something else there was one example
where she was talked about facts she was
asked about facts when she had just been
lying and then she responded with
something like you want to talk about
facts how about the fact that and then
she criticized Obama so she's a constant
liar and read
rector but she's actually really skilled
ok so maybe uh Kellyanne Conway is it
has been pseudo blacklisted but also it
seems that the Trump team is keeping her
off the radar for a little bit so that's
not a good sign if she can't be publicly
useful it's not clear that she's
privately useful she may go okay so
those are a few thoughts and we'll see
who else might be on that list we've got
a ten dollar super chat from 15 year old
justin rossman who says hey David I'm
relatively new to politics only 15 and a
big fan of the show I was wondering if
you could elaborate on the reasons by
progressives oppose TPP and other free
trade deals I think we have to separate
actually great question from Justin
great that you're involved at age 15 we
have two separate free trade deals and
TPP TPP was a corporate power deal it
was being called a free trade deal but
it was really a pro corporate boon which
would number one lift multinational
companies from being subjected to the
legal systems of individual countries to
those of this sort of arbitration system
that well is just a big big corporate
boon because those same corporations
would have a say inter as far as who
would be on that arbitration committee
it was a mess okay it would strengthen
copyright and intellectual intellectual
property law in a way that would be
great for big corporations and bad for
consumers it would weaken environmental
restrictions in a way that would be more
profitable for big corporations and
worse for the environment so I don't
think that we can say in an umbrella
fashion that liberals are against free
trade deals and TPP for the same reasons
free trade is a different thing and the
problem with free trade is it's often
not really free and also when anytime we
talk about something being free we have
to say well you can make something free
on paper but you might be paying for
other stuff okay that's one thing and
are things really free when you consider
the negative externalities and this is a
broader conversation about
trade deals but hopefully that gives you
a little bit of a sense thank you to
Matthew upchurch who has just signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership but
we have a coupon code which gives you
forty percent off membership you get all
the stuff you just don't pay as much
that's a pretty good deal the coupon
code is i voted 17 i'm going to get to
chuck Davis's comment I've been seeing a
bunch of stuff scrolling buying the chat
about the israeli-palestinian conflict a
lot of people like to call me a Zionist
which I find to be a completely
meaningless attempt at it ad hominem
asked me my specific positions about an
issue user Lakers suck okay that's
that's the user's name actually asked a
good question because it's a specific
question about policy David what do you
think about Israel pushing for new
settlements I am unilaterally opposed to
new settlements in Israel they are an
impediment to peace when Trump nominated
David Friedman who has the completely
extremist view of wanting more
settlements in Israel I immediately
denounced it I am categorically against
settlements I from a pragmatic
perspective recognize that if we're
going to have real productive
israeli-palestinian peace talks that
there is going to have to be some level
of a land swap probably probably for
some of the more established settlements
that practically speaking are not going
to be dismantled I'm not saying I favor
that I'm taking a pragmatic perspective
which is settlement building needs to
stop immediately settlements that are
small absolutely need to be be halted
and people should move out of there the
bigger settlements that have been around
for a while you're probably going to
need to do land swaps even Yasser Arafat
recognized that land swaps would be okay
as long as its equivalent land you can't
take land that's a better position so to
speak in a settlement and then offer up
for a potential Palestinian state
crappyland okay for lack of a better
term and we could talk about what what
that means so yes I am completely
completely against settlements in Israel
okay somebody asked if I'm gay on
matters no I'm not gay but let me get
back to the Super chat okay Chuck Davis
has now outdone we had Michael Smith
with a $41 72 cents super chat which was
the new high water mark for a super chat
and now we have chuck davis besting that
number with a $45 super chat saying i am
a trunk supporting conservative who is
challenging himself to listen to the
other side i challenge you all to do the
same we're all Americans we need to
improve discourse spread the love y'all
if this is true it is stunning to me
that a trump supporting conservative
paid forty five dollars just to tell our
audience which is currently 636 people
that they should be open to ideas from
the other side but I i I'm I'm
speechless I'm without speech i don't i
don't know what else to say but thank
you chuck for that message Wes smoke who
west smoke signed up for membership a
few minutes ago with the coupon code i
voted 17 and now has also sent the three
dollar and 14 sent super chat saying i
just wanted to give you pi is 3.14 the
first three digits of pi thank you so
much wes really appreciate it we have a
five dollar super chat from zion train
ism who says david what actions need to
be made to rebuild the democratic party
from the ground up and not let corporate
democrats take over okay first of i I
address this in pretty significant
detail after the election so we've got a
number of different videos that you can
look at from November ninth and sort of
the couple of weeks follow following
that I have many many many thoughts on
this part of it is the DNC chair we need
to have a DNC chair that understands
that so that's a big thing and we also
need to recognize that Bernie might have
one Bernie might have defeated Trump I'm
not saying Bernie definitely would have
I am only saying that when we talk about
77,000 boats in three states that were
very very close and you consider the
baggage that Hillary Clinton had it
possible that Bernie Sanders would have
would have won and we need to be
thinking about that in terms of what it
means as far as the appetite that
left-leaning independence and Democratic
voters have right now I think that the
biggest mistake Democrats can make is
being Republican light oh we're fiscally
conservative too but we still want
social programs explain why fiscal
conservatism is Republicans see it is
absolutely bogus and explain how real
fiscal conservatism is eliminating the
need for social welfare programs by
improving the economy through
recognizing that trickle-down economics
is a total fantasy right we needs to be
a deeper conversation and it is
absolutely a great question and it's the
right question to be asking right now
big thank you to Hayden Connor Hayden
Connor just went to david pakman.com
slash membership and signed up for
membership using the coupon code I voted
17 the coupon code gives you 40 percent
off you get a hundred percent of the
member benefits including the daily
commercial free TV show the members only
audio podcast the daily members only
bonus show blah blah blah blah blah you
get a hundred percent of the stuff but
you pay forty percent less so use the
coupon code I voted 17 we have a five
euro super chat from user visiting
dublin saying i was wondering if anyone
noticed actually that the letters on
Trump's notes in orlando were huge a few
people sent me links to Trump's notes
from the recent rally and there was
really big stuff it looked like it was
written in a sharpie on the piece of
paper I don't know if anybody's taken a
closer look at whether there's anything
of interest there but yeah I did notice
that as I was watching it by the way why
is Trump holding campaign rallies when
there is no campaign although from a
legal standpoint Trump actually filed
for the beginning of his reelection
campaign on Inauguration Day and that
has implications with regard to the
ability to raise money and a few other
things with regard to
the way in which other nonprofits can
criticize Donald Trump that's also
impacted by Trump already running for
re-election okay people asking about
people asking about the future of the
Republican Party as well in light of
Trump I don't know that we I want to
address this right now the future of the
Republican Party as we know it is going
to depend on what happens to Trump's
approval rating in the next could be
three months could be six months could
be year and a half as we close in on the
midterm elections Donald Trump's
approval rating has been sort of
trickling down a little bit if it gets
too low you're going to see more
Republicans jumping ship I think that
there are probably Republicans that like
Trump's policies and there are
definitely Republicans that think Trump
is out of his mind but they're basically
willing to as most corporate politicians
are do what they need to do to get
reelected and if it appears as though
denouncing Trump will help them in terms
of their 2018 re-election campaigns then
they are going to denounce Trump if it
seems as though staying on the Trump
train will help them for their 2018
re-election campaigns then it's likely
that they are going to support Trump and
a lot of it is going to be determined by
that so I think it's too early to say
what the future of the Republican Party
is at this point there's no doubt
however that the election of Trump has
absolutely impacted the views of the
both mainstream parties Democrats in
terms of what can happen to them when
someone like Trump runs and Republicans
in terms of how they lost control of
their primary and weren't able to push
through whoever it was that they wanted
to have in there and at this point I
guess it's hard to be totally sure
exactly who that even was okay
memberships pouring in I venture to say
Geraldine hunt as well as william
mcbride both signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code i voted 17 people saying
David you're talking
membership but what is it this program
is free okay we've been doing an hour a
day radio show TV show youtube show etc
for years the program has always been
free it continues to be free the way we
pay for the cost of production and staff
and the studio and equipment and
software all of this stuff is through
membership and in exchange for
membership for people signing up we give
you benefits one is that you have a
daily commercial free TV show and
members-only audio podcast we also do a
daily bonus show which is just for our
paid subscribers we talked about behind
the scenes stuff we talked about other
stories etc etc so please sign up it
really means a lot when people sign up
and we've seen a record nearly 400 new
members in the month of februari I think
our previous record was like 210 or
something and we surpassed that days ago
so we've already got a record month and
we're on track to blowing that further
out of the water and you can sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership the
coupon code it's available a new member
is a new member whether you pay full
price or not and the coupon code i voted
17 we'll get you a forty percent
discount which is absolutely fantastic
now at the beginning of this stream i
mentioned we had a huge tech disaster
today no fault of anybody on staff
please don't go and read it and start
slamming producer pat the way people did
after he mentioned yesterday that he
uses a Keurig for his coffee consumption
we don't yet have today's a full show up
we have the bonus show up but we don't
yet have the full show up or a couple
hours behind because of the tech issues
that we had today okay alright a couple
other things i want to mention i already
am looking at some broader stories for
next week one of the stories i want to
look at is that more aspects of the
Donald Trump Russian blackmail dossier
or file call it a file if you want have
been corroborated right now there's
basically two one relates to Carter
page an oil executive and foreign policy
advisor another relates to Paul Manafort
okay and slowly it's trickling in drip
drip drip we're learning that more and
more aspects of the Trump Russian
dossier have been corroborated does
Donald Trump get off by urinating on
women prostitutes in Russia that is one
of the more outlandish claims from the
dossier that has not been corroborated
but the idea that the entire thing is
just made up has been widely widely
debunked at this point and we will see
what else we learn about that also i
plan to talk next week the muslim
brotherhood is going to be listed as a
terrorist group by more countries and i
am sort of surprised that this is even
considered controversial i think that
that's the correct designation i also
think that hamas is obviously a
terrorist group Hezbollah is a terrorist
group etc etc I I don't think that these
these things are controversial and I
know some people don't like that in the
table David what about all the American
white terrorist groups hey the right
hates that I constantly remind everybody
that the more most prevalent
perpetrators of terror in the united
states are just american-born white
dudes right that that's a reality so I
think we have to deal with the facts we
have to deal with the fact the fact is
that these are terrorist groups the
facts are that worldwide the most common
perpetrators of terrorism are Muslim men
but in the United States the most common
perpetrators of terror are American born
white men and recently I am I'm part of
something called the glass Leadership
Institute part of the anti-defamation
league we had an expert come in I want
to say two months ago one month ago to
talk to us about Islamic terror and we
had an expert come in a few weeks ago
and it was exclusively focused on
domestic right wing
terror actually it was on domestic
terror broadly we talked a little bit
about left-wing domestic American terror
and there are relatively few examples of
it I mean you have a few sort of what
are called eco terrorist incidents but
by and large we're talking about right
wing white dude terror in the United
States people have asked me to comment a
little bit about the the death of Alan
Colmes okay and let me do that I knew
Alan Colmes personally and alan colmes
progressive radio host passed away this
morning at 66 from what's being
described as a brief illness I first was
in touch with alan colmes in 2005 i
think i had started my program at the
time it wasn't even the david pakman
show it was called mid-week politics at
the time it was every other wednesday
wednesday the source of calling it
midweek and i emailed that one and in
fact i can i can tell you a little bit
about our exchanges because i can look
them up in my email here i emailed him
and i basically said hey I'm big fan of
yours and I am interested in growing my
show and getting more into talk radio
and he wrote me back very very early on
and said it's great that you're doing
this maybe tried to volunteer at an
existing radio station maybe try to get
an internship keep doing what you're
doing and then in 2008 I emailed him
again and I said I don't know if you
remember me but I emailed you saying I'm
interested in getting into radio and you
know you gave me some advice and the
show is growing and I'm so glad and he
wrote me back right away and said I'm
glad that this is what's going on
congratulations keep it going and then
in 2013 when I was close to moving to
New York City Alan Colmes actually
reached out to me the youtube show had
gotten popular enough that he was paying
some attention to it and he said hey I'm
really interested in what you're doing
are you ever in New York and I said I'm
moving to New York let's get together
and we started a relationship and I got
together with Alan a couple of times he
showed up at my studio he just came to
my tie this tiny studio in lower
Manhattan
and alan colmes came over he brought
over his web guy who also was interested
in seeing what my setup was and we just
hung out and chatted he had me up to his
fox news radio studio and had me on his
program could not be a nicer guy we
would email back and forth every few
months and most recently we emailed
after the election of Trump and we were
just sort of commenting that if there's
a silver lining it's that more
progressives are engaged that we've got
to take advantage of the increased
engagement to really do what we can with
the progressive message and that was
just a few months ago and I learned
today that he had passed away so it is
truly sad such a great person and many
of my friends in the radio community and
the media community to say devastated i
think is accurate and and i've been
seeing the messages on facebook etc so
truly sad i did not know that alan
colmes was ill and sad very very sad
okay thank you to a few other new
members while I've just been chatting
here okay i mentioned hayden connor
Brooks McFarland has signed up with the
coupon code I voted 17 Carla Gras bird
signed up with the coupon code I voted
seventeen Yves Curtis signed up with the
coupon code I voted 17 which again gives
you forty percent off Rafael losa
Trevino has signed up with the coupon
code no opting to pay full price did
Raphael and Michael Smith Michael Smith
also signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership okay I saw while I was
talking about Alan a bunch of super
chats went by Matthew upchurch sent one
for a dollar seventy-five who else was
in there Paul W sent a five-dollar super
chat with hashtag Pakman 2020 I was not
born in the United States so I
unfortunately cannot run for president
fortunately or unfortunately depends on
your perspective an EK sending a
five-dollar super chat saying Pakman
2020 please thank you for doing what you
do again
I was not born in the United States and
as a naturalized citizen I cannot run
for president that's as far up as the
chat let's me go right now if I missed
any others i do apologize all right new
show tomorrow i was born in bonus itís
argentina for people asking i could run
for a different office hmm i don't know
might be able to have more impact as as
a media person thanks to everybody who
joined me use that coupon code please
sign up we do depend on your support and
the more support we have the more live
content we could do studio tour coming
up blah blah blah blah blah lots of good
stuff all right saludos to everybody
asking me to speak Spanish will do
another one of these soon